okay der turm verbrennt höhe sowie bis
zu wissen wo bist du das hier eine schad
region oder was ist hier los
worauf noch nicht so eine übung mit dem
jetpack die wolle
vor allen dingen wiederkommen ich schlag
den fachgruppen einer bloßen hand ja
halte ich habe mir noch auf jeden fall
cola und muss
darum welche hier heilfroh ich möchte da
nicht ich möchte hier marschieren 54
wolle was kennt ihn hier noch
wegschmeißen
ich weiß nicht recht nicht erst mal ein
steak kann ich nicht aus einer wolle den
schlecht das inventar an wege natürlich
nicht schade dass da könnte ich mir dann
so schöne pferden aus zaubern aber geht
nicht
so sind nur mehr schaffe auch hier sind
überall schaaf ist das schön
ich weiß nicht was ich mit der ganzen
wolle mache aber ok ich hab' 63 das
müsste reichen wenn ich dann nachher da
bin sage ich dann 63 wolle hätte ich mal
mehr mitgenommen das brauche ich ja
nicht nur den diamanten
dreimal ist nötig da ist dieses wissen
wieder da will ich auch gar nicht hin
laufen zu diesem fest möchten hier nur
noch die volle holen und dann möchte ich
möglichst schnell weg fliegen umher
wenn ich aber schaffe bei mir zuhause
von da ist relativ unnötig was ich
gerade zwei anstalten ist noch kohle die
nicht auch noch eben mit alkohol das
machen und dann ab zurück und kompatibel
machen
ach komm ich sprint jetzt ist egal ja
das ist ein langer rückweg was kann ich
immer was kann ich denn quatschen
meine situation in letzter zeit und zwar
ist der klausur fahrt jetzt wohl dieses
video seht ist klausurphase glaube ich
neben im voraus auf den mann nimmt auch
im voraus aufregen weil den urlaub fährt
da könnte ich mal eben ganz kurz oben
reingucken
das ist jetzt im internet becker kann
einfach um rein fliegen das ist
allerdings gleich auch schon wieder
aufgebraucht meinte becker muss dass es
wieder aufladen
5000 taste ich mich da so an und fliegt
dann der hoch einfach ist alles ganz
legitim was wir hier machen mit voraus
aufnehmen
wo sind die stoner
halo ist überhaupt irgendwas das ist
einfach nur tun
denn hat man theoretisch okay der turm
verbrennt so was das da unten noch das
wohnhaus da waren wir wirklich noch
keiner drin oder das sind alles nur
diese komischen sachen die hier
hinzugefügt wurden deswegen kenne ich
mich da überhaupt nicht aus wir nehmen
im voraus auf weil ich klausurphase habe
und jetzt mal an alle älteren zuschauer
das musste ich mich in letzter zeit
entscheiden was ich mit ins abi nehmen
möchte doch hier war schon jemand was
haltet ihr von ich muss ich muss so wie
mit mit schriftlichen abi nehme ich bin
nicht so der sowie fan wenn man will
dann ist es ja ganz interessant aber ihr
könntet ihr einfach schreiben an alle
die die guten sowie sind sowie
sozialwissenschaften politik bei anderen
heißt es vivo glaube ich nico
wirtschaftspolitik heißt es bei denen
zum beispiel der hätte das auch
mündliche aber ich hab's schriftlichen
abi deswegen würde ich mich sehr freuen
wenn ihr mir tipps in die kommentare
schreiben könnte was ihr bezüglich des
so alle sist bzw
auf die mir sagen können ob ihr das auch
hattet ob er das gut fällt ob die das im
ab jetzt schlecht ist so was alles halt
so ich bin gleich wieder zu hause mein
gepäck ist auch hier im moment alle
kommen dann seht ihr offizielles zu fuß
weiter die wüste kann ich ja gehen
so und ist alle 1300 ja also das sowas
können einfach in die kommentare
schreiben
würde ich mich sehr freuen und halt wie
immer dann weitere tipps hat warum soll
ich das überhaupt sind gerade mit neuen
erfolge zu jedem moment hat manager pack
auf die arbeit für mich zufall
verrichten 800 so leute ihr fahrrad ist
leicht bergauf wird zuviel 400 ich muss
nur noch über diesen komischen rollen
gekommen weil habe ich keinen bock zu
laufen
lospech du schaffst das jetpack ja
die welt das noch
ich glaube das hört wenn ich jetzt mal
so hoch fliege ich gehe jetzt mal ganze
zeit hoch
ich glaube zwischendurch wird immer ein
bisschen auf weil ich wirklich immer so
auf den nullpunkt manchmal bin aber dass
das legt sich einmal wieder auf das
heißt ich habe quasi unendlich jetpack
stimmt das kann quasi gar nicht nicht
aufhören es kann nicht nicht aufhören es
kann nicht aufhören es kann ich nicht
als er doppelt gemoppelt club dass
simons auch schon cool und da ist er
onyx dingsbums und da ist ein portal
linksaußen ende sieht echt so scheiße
aus einfach nur so ich bin sofort wieder
bei mir zu hause machen wir kompakter
machen wir uns einen low voltage ding
und dann habe ich mehr energie habe auch
eine größere bett box oder dann packe
ich die ärzte erst mal bei mir rein und
dann ja haben wir es dann auch
so wolle kommt hier rein steine kinostar
sortieren wolle habe ich jetzt
anderthalb stacks das schon mal ganz gut
er kommt ein stern seien hier kommen die
ganzen ärzte dann rein du du du du ja
diamant kohle da das verändert sich wenn
die schiffbrücke saphir uranium hart
hier kommt dann so was rein so seltenere
sachen zum beispiel das oder wie zum
beispiel dass werkzeuge party ganz
einfach ich hier unten rein lover einmal
kann ich auch noch hier mit reinpacken
die lava einmal sind auch in einer
gewissen vorlegen dass wertvolles dass
hierauf sind ja immer noch werkzeuge
sie soll das ganze kann ich jetzt nicht
im ofen tun sondern das pack ich in den
mails rater genau das funktioniert
überhaupt hallo funktioniert ist
ich bin selbst gespannt weil ich weiß
dass gerade zum ersten mal bei mir
selber ja okay das ist gut zwei koffer
das major mit brauche auf jeden fall
schonmal besseren europa und da ich
klatschen auf einmal kommt so eine
fliege ich krieg' ich mache so zeigt auf
eine fliege raus kai degen
ich glaube ich mache das trotzdem kann
ich meinen das ist jetzt keine sache ob
ich das jetzt bei mir mache oder bei
käfer davon keinen nachteil
ja also obwohl ich da für sein
grundstück betreten aber kev meinte ich
darf das machen von daher sollte das
glaub ich keine schwierigkeit darstellen
kann ich euch das immer noch mal ganz
kurz park zeigen
marc hat da hinten nämlich da sind seine
ganzen solarpanels und ja so ab zugriff
da rein guckt ob ich das jetzt daran die
evag darin das ist ein rotary major ist
einfach nur schneller deswegen müssen ob
wir jetzt bei mir tausend jahre warten
oder ob wir das jetzt einfach hierbei
greift jetzt keinen unterschied kann ich
dann liegen und in eurem leben packen
bronze körper
ach so ich glaube dass beides wird dann
vereint oder wird das war eigentlich
wird in dem wir doch zu tun oder
er verstehe ich gar nicht wie
das funktioniert auf jeden fall auch
nicht das ist auch komisch na gut was
ist wenn ich da noch ein rein tun
es gibt ja nix aber wenn ich meine team
wird auch nicht verbrauchte das wird
dann etwa nutzen bank sodass doch es
wird verbraucht aber was soll ich damit
bronze
kann man sich mit bronze ist um machen
sie sich besser als eisenbahn oder so
ich weiß es gar nicht praktisch schon
mal ganz kurz hier ein branche wird
bronze raus na gut ich bin ich auch
erfahrungen die kriegt man nicht so
wenig zinsen reinzukriegen nicht im dass
das heißt sie vermischen sich dann
irgendwie sowie in so einem mixer oder
so wenn man zwei verschiedene sachen
rein tut dann wird etwas verschiedenes
sowie bei diesem komischen elemente
spiel da wo man wenn man wasser und erde
leben so etwas kennen bestimmt einige
von euch passt
mehr ja
induction furness den muss ich auf jeden
fall noch mal machen ich brauche
induction von rotary misrata droht terry
wey skater wie fein ironman triathlons
maschinen blog mach ich das
defoe hatte die ganzen sachen 11 na gut
ich meine dass wir dann unser nächstes
ziel seinen rotary major ich weiß ich
habe heute eine menge zeit deswegen wäre
ich wahrscheinlich eine menge aufnehmen
ihr werdet dann eine menge folgen voraus
gingen aber da ich alleine aufnehmen ist
es nicht so schlimm weil das ist nur
schlimm wenn ich dann zum beispiel mit
der onyx zum beispiel aufnehme
stell dir vor ich mit sonic auf und die
folge kommt bei ihm an einem tag und bei
mir dann allerdings drei wochen später
dann wär ich quasi so der neue smart
mehr oder weniger weil das freibad zu
ich habe voll hochladen drei wochen
später war die bei spark auf dem kanal
und das wollen wir nicht das westbad
nicht deswegen haben wir diese regelung
eingeführt dass man nur 30 minuten
täglich hochladen darf halo cavalli zu
gerade 514 minuten hoch ich habe zwölf
freie tage an dem ich noch 45 minuten
hochladen darf weil ich am anfang 12 10
15 minuten habe er das jetzt nicht
verstanden wird in libyen und entweder
du packte seine sachen und gehst oder du
packst du fährst freunde das ist so das
motto
hier sieht also heißt du nicht einfach
die tür aufmachen aber nicht darf es
nicht ich sitze schon kurz t shirt kurze
was ist bitte ein langes t shirt so
danke dafür dass das verwenden durfte
das übrigens diese lampe kann ich bei
mir immer dran machen geht natürlich
auch natürlich darüber was mit jetpack
am start 1000 geht da ja schön also mich
freut's immer zu sehen dass es dann
klappt ich beschäftige mich ja immer
mehr mitglied begießt und ich glaube das
ist auch in ihrem interesse einige meine
natürlich erstmal haus
jetzt geht's erst mal mitglied bist du
richtig ab freunde
weil das meint ihr alle dass sie mich
damit beschäftigen soll und ja also
jetzt erstmal ein bisschen die division
abklatschen form einen tollen bäumchen
vom heimlichen schild schreiben kommt
wichtig wer ist das der der das bei mir
machte höher auf wer auch immer diese
schilder schreibt höher auf das ist mein
grundstück und wenn er das macht könnte
er theoretisch ins gefängnis gehen meint
rita bz schreibt das jetzt mal eben kurz
in den conti jetzt heute glaube ich ganz
gut hier noch
da hab ich nicht noch voll viele tipps
nicht glauben ich drei reichen es mal so
schreibt das mal ganz kurz in die konfi
vom heimlichen schild schreiber wenn das
noch einmal passiert dass auf meinem gs
tausende schild umhängen soll der im
gefängnis so leute wenn ihr das bei
anderen leuten ihnen wie gesehen ob das
der bei mir schilder geschehen und sagt
mir das bitte dann seid ihr keine plätze
dann seid ihr nur ein produkt meiner
meiner wut dementsprechend
ich werde auch immer das ist finde ich
es eh so prime könig wetten
komisch dass man fliegt meint auch
welche das was in den blättern sein kann
alles mit ihrer digital
dann sollen sie doch weiter rum stehen
die gladbacher
ich hab gedacht ich keine tiere die
platte abschlagen dann ist viel mehr
fläche für das die krisen darum an den
baum zu kommen an den stamm aber dann
wird das glaube ich nicht funktionieren
alles so kommt hier rein egal ist es
kostenlos schilder dadurch von daher
kann ich
fakt ist jetzt vergessen kann ich dann
gucken in extractor ja dann kommt er
raus und ich mache mir jetzt ein paar
koffer cable erstmal das heißt
solarpanel draufklicken solarpanel marke
paco rabanne und kopper ich habe gar
nicht mehr so viel rabatt sollen
ich hab mich viele opfer kümmern sollen
egal dafür geht das ja nicht hier geht's
ab sondern da geht es gerade ab ja toll
wisst ihr was freunde ich parteien statt
mit mal ganz kurz man was ist das
eigentlich wofür brauche ich das juni
wie ich an isoliert kopper cable da
kriege ich ja immer mit raus warte ich
schon mal ganz kurz mit kupferkabel
nicht auch aus diesem an isolierten
dings ja es stimmt einfach nur ein
koffer daneben dann kann ich das ja
theoretisch bei ihm machen mache ich das
nicht die ganze zeit schon so ich meine
ich habe ja noch ganz viel davon hier ja
da mach ich das auch in zukunft einfach
immer so
ich meine ich hab davon mehrere sex oder
warte mal ganz kurz
ja stimmt da kriegt aber sechs daraus ja
dann ist ja meine movie aufnahme wurde
automatisch angehalten
komisch